If you're struggling with your diet,
just can't sustain those healthy eating habits
you're not alone.
Might I suggest the Plant Power Meal Planner,
our digital toolbox of unlimited access
to thousands of customizable plant-based recipes
integrated with grocery delivery
experts support seven days a week and so much more
all for just a $1.90 a week to learn more and sign up,
visit meals.richrolls.com.
Do it now, okay, let's do the show.
I moved to America when I was 25
and I just left everything behind
and I came with two suitcases
and I barely spoke the language,
but it is such a liberating feeling
to know that everything you need is inside of you.
You don't need anything else.
And I mean, only COVID could have given me
this experience again so late in life at 44 years old,
where I was literally sitting in my apartment
a year ago not knowing if I'm gonna have a restaurant,
not knowing how to pay for the bills for the business
and coming to terms with the idea,
I might lose it all and it's okay.
And when you get to that place,
and I hope I don't need to get physically to that place
again, but I hope mentally I can get myself
into that space for many, many years to come
because in that space you're very free
and you're able to make pretty bold moves without fear.
That's Daniel Humm, and this is the Rich Roll Podcast.
(soft music)
The Rich Roll Podcast.
Okay, what happens when one of,
if not the greatest restaurants in the world
suddenly seemingly out of the blue goes 100% plant-based.
Well for perspective in context
of the 132 three star Michelin restaurants around the world,
not a single one is vegan.
So with that, most would say such a move
is tantamount to financial suicide,
but Daniel Humm, the world renowned chef
and owner of 11 Madison Park sees it differently.
He sees it as purpose-driven, mission-based
and the greatest creative challenge of his lifetime,
a native of Switzerland, a former pro cyclist,
and a 251 marathoner Daniel started cooking at 14
preparing exquisite meals
and some of the finest Swiss hotels and restaurants
before earning his first Michelin star at the age of 24,
in 2003, he moved to the US to become the executive chef
at Campton place in San Francisco,
where he received four stars
from the San Francisco Chronicle.
Three years later, recruited by Danny Meyer.
Daniel moves to New York
and becomes the executive chef at 11 Madison Park.
And he revitalizes this restaurant so completely
that in 2017, it was named number one on the coveted list
of the world's 50 best restaurants.
That's all amazing of course,
but the story really gets interesting when the pandemic hits
like most restaurants, 11 Madison Park closed its stores.
They did that for almost a year and teetered on bankruptcy,
but it was during this time that Daniel,
like many of us started thinking more deeply
about things like purpose, what he stands for
and how he could leverage this talent of his
and the resources at his disposal
to more meaningfully participate in solutions
to things like food insecurity,
the ills of animal agriculture,
and more broadly the inherent unsustainable nature
of food systems.
In a moment of clarity,
he decides to make this crazy bold change
first by converting his kitchen into a commissary
and kitting out a food truck to provide free meals
to food insecure New Yorkers,.
He partners with this organization,
this nonprofit called Rethink Food,
which is committed to creating sustainable and equitable
food system solutions at scale.
And finally, upon EMP's recent reopening
turns the most revered restaurant in the world plant-based
a restaurant where every meal enjoyed,
pays for five meals freely provided to those in need.
And that decision when announced was like this bombshell
sending the food world into a frenzy,
but Daniel's bet is paying off
within hours of the announcement.
11 Madison Park booked a full month of reservations.
And today just five weeks later,
the waitlist exceeds 15,000 people.
Brevity is not the sole of my wit today
I've got much more to say
about the amazing conversation to come,
Okay, Danielle, so this is what went down
the day that 11 Madison Park announced its new menu,
which was covered extensively in the media.
I knew I immediately wanted to get Daniel on the show
as soon as possible because my news feed blowing up
with people commenting about this incredible story.
And my friend past podcast, guests,
former food and drinks editor for Esquire,
Jeff Gordoneer who had profiled Daniel for Esquire
on the New York Times, connected us.
Daniel agreed to do the show,
but he made that agreement on one condition
that I first dine at 11 Madison Park.
And I'm not one to say no to that.
So I immediately booked my flight to New York City.
I joined Jeff for said dinner,
which was, I don't even know how to describe it.
It was exquisite, it was divine,
it was like this performance art,
unlike anything I had previously experienced
admittedly rare privilege.
And the following day, I sat down with Daniel
for the conversation you're about to enjoy.
It's a conversation about why food at this level
food as curated experience food is art is important.
It's about what makes a great chef,
a great restaurant great in the first place.
And it's about what it really means to pursue a passion.
It's also about constant reinvention,
but more than anything,
this is a conversation about personal evolution,
the search for meaning and purpose beyond accolades
and what it means to mature your career
and devote your talents into something mission-based
in service to a better world.
Daniel is remarkable.
His story is wildly fascinating.
And I don't feel it's an overstatement to say that
he is now one of the most important figures
in the plant-based movement.
I believe 11 Madison Park because of its stature
because of what this move represents.
And because of what Daniel imagined and is now creating
is well-poised to forever change the restaurant industry.
And also how people think about what plant-based
cuisine is and can be.
It was an honor to experience his talents.
It was an honor to spend time with him.
And it's an honor to share our exchange with you.
So without further ado, this is me
and one of not the best chefs in the world, Daniel Humms.
All right, we're good to do this.
How are you doing thanks for doing this today.
I'm good, so happy to be here.
That's very, very sweet of you to say,
I am thrilled to be talking to you today.
Thank you for making the time
and thank you for making room for me at the restaurant
last night, Jeff Gordoneer you and I had an exquisite meal
curated by you and your wonderful staff.
It's a memory that I won't soon forget.
And it was really quite something.
I have so many takeaways from the experience,
not the least of which is coming into this realization
that you, as the chef and like the team leader,
of course the centerpiece of this experience is the food,
but there's so much more
that goes into curating this experience.
You have to be this gregarious host.
You have to be present with all of the patrons,
despite whatever chaos is going on in the kitchen.
And I noticed an extraordinary equanimity
in your disposition as you greeted everybody
and spent time with each of the patrons that had,
you know, I'm sure it looked forward to this experience
and it really belies the trope of the screaming chef
and the chaos and anarchy
that we've come to sort of believe to be the rule,
as opposed to the exception.
I know you had your moments in the past
with that kind of behavior,
but I didn't see any indication of that last night.
No, I think when you lose your cool as a chef,
it is a weakness.
And I mean, we've all been in this situation,
we as chefs have all been in these situations
where we lose our cool or were in an environment
where other people are losing their cool,
but it is really a weakness of the organization
of the restaurant.
And today I think kitchens are far from that
and especially ours.
I mean, it's pretty well oiled machine
and we have so many talented people,
so there's really no need for that kind of behavior.
Right, if you have your management structure sorted out
and you are being an effective leader,
from kind of a military perspective,
then there shouldn't be those problems.
If you're resorting to that kind of behavior,
it means there's something broken in that chain of command.
That's exactly right.
That's exactly, and in fact, it's a shame that
there are TV shows portraying that kind of behavior
because it's really not how it is, it's not.
Yeah.
No.
You've had...
You used to do a little bit of that though back in the day.
I mean, what is really difficult
is when you're a young chef to get to the top
or to be recognized you have to do it
with a lot less resources
than with the people you're competing with.
Like today we have, you know, we...
It costs a certain amount to eat at the restaurant.
Yeah.
People from all over the world wanna work with me.
So we have so much going for us,
but when you're young and you know,
the meal can't be that expensive, no one knows who you are.
So you're working with just whoever you find.
And it's kind of like a smoking mirror kind of situation
to rise up up the ranks.
And so it's just a lot of pressure on the individual
who is trying to make sure.
I wanna get into the reinvention,
the re imagination of food, all the exciting developments
that are taking place at 11 Madison Park.
But before we do that,
I think it would be cool to spend a few minutes
just talking about the importance of cuisine in general.
And just by way of personal background,
I'm a pretty simple guy.
I'm a rice and beans and guacamole dude.
Like I eat proper food.
I've been plant-based for a long time.
My tastes are not that refined.
I have had privileged experiences,
a couple of eating at fine establishment,
yours being certainly one of them I ate at Noma two years
ago with Jeff I've eaten at Lara Pesh.
I've had those experiences, but I wouldn't consider myself
like a gastronomist by any stretch of the imagination.
So and I think it's important to say like,
most people in their lives will never have the privilege
of dining at your restaurant
or a similar analogous type situation.
So why, like, why is cuisine at this level important?
How do you think about food as art at the highest level
and the impact that has
and the meaning that carries throughout culture?
Well, I think it's an art form.
I've always cooked in those restaurants.
From the beginning of my career,
I worked in these Michelin star restaurants.
And for me, the way I've I've experienced it
was as a performance and as an art form.
And it's very much tied to culture of the place.
Like when you're working in a restaurant in France
or in Italy or in South America,
those experiences are very much different.
They're very much tied to the place
and they're making references to the culture.
And of course coming, I grew up in Switzerland
and fine dining for us was coming out of France,
which is maybe even the birthplace of that kind of dining.
I think there's a beautiful culture tied to it.
And it starts from the farmers,
the artisans who make the ceramics and the silverware
and the glass blowing.
And then it's the people who make the linens
and then of course the team that works the floor
and the way they move through the dining room.
And then of course the chefs and then the recipes
they're inspired by that go way back sometimes.
So I think it's...
And I struggled with this many times in my life
with the idea of how much it costs to eat
at one of those restaurants,
because food is so magical on so many levels
and food touches everyone and to cook for an audience
of the 1% that can be challenging sometimes.
But through the pandemic,
somehow I found a whole new meaning in all of it.
Like our restaurant shut down March 16 of last year.
And all we have left was an empty space
farmers with so much food that was going bad
and food insecurity that was doubling.
And so we transformed 11 Madison Park
into a community kitchen.
Yeah, so you go from in 2017,
the restaurants rated the number one restaurant in the world
on that coveted 50 world's best list.
I'm sure with that,
there's pressure to continue what you're doing,
the way that you're doing it.
It's obviously working and it's attracting people
from all over the world and you're being alauded for it.
And you're getting all this attention 2020 hits.
You're forced to close the restaurant
you're facing bankruptcy.
You make some interesting pivots during the pandemic year,
but in 2021, you open as a 100% plant-based restaurant.
None of the, other of the 132 three star restaurants
are vegan, I mean, that requires immense balls
to make such a bold move.
But reinvention is really the touchdown of everything
that you've done historically throughout
not just your career but your life,
like you're constantly pivoting and iterating
and challenging yourself to do something fresh and new.
I think it's one part for selfish reasons
to keep myself interested in it,
because I don't see myself doing the same thing
over and over again.
And especially after experiencing the pandemic,
I definitely didn't wanna go back
to doing what we did before.
Yeah, it seems like it's a bit of a reckoning.
I mean, I think in the sort of hoity-toity
high altitude of cuisine at this level,
there's a lot of discussion and dialogue
about things that are important within that subculture,
but actually don't really matter, you know
they're nice, they're ego inflating, et cetera.
But the pandemic, my sense is that
it really compelled you to kind of confront your path
in a very existential way.
And it provided you this opportunity to re-imagine
and infuse your talent and everything that you do
with this extraordinary mission-based level of purpose
and intention that can help people beyond
the very few who can experience the food at 11 Madison Park.
Now, for sure, and in 2017, when we became one,
it was actually not such a great,
it wasn't as great as one would imagine that feeling
it was actually coming with a lot of emptiness
and maybe it has to do that.
This was a goal that we were chasing for so long
probably for 10 years that number one spot
was sort of our carrot that we were chasing
and you've done marathons and triathlons.
And sometimes when you train a lot for an event
and then you have the event and you're on such a high,
you can kind of fall into a hole a little bit
where you're a little depressed.
And I think that's definitely what happened to me
after becoming number one.
And I was looking for more meaning
I was looking for a higher purpose
and then the pandemic hit and sort of,
I realized that my language is food is cooking.
And actually food is part of everyone's lives,
but food is so central to so many problems we're facing
on this planet food insecurity being one
global warming and farming and so much more.
And so I found myself in this spot
of having this kind of incredible opportunity
to actually say something through the food,
to show a delicious way to cooking with only plants
and feeling that could make a real difference.
The precursor to this is this decision to open up
11 Madison Park as a commissary kitchen
and start providing meals to the food insecure.
And doing that in partnership with Rethink,
which was founded by one of your former cooks.
Yeah
Right
So walk me through that chapter.
Yeah, so one of our cooks three years before the pandemic
who worked with us,
he said, hey, I see you're having all these leftovers
or these parts of like.
You know, we are only using the top part of a broccoli
and the stem we don't use and that is true
to so many other ingredients.
And he said, "What if I would take all these ingredients
"and if I would have a little commissary kitchen
"and I would make meals out of these ingredients
"for people in need would you be able to support me?"
So we founded together this organization called Rethink Food
that was relying on restaurants,
supplying them with their leftovers.
And we did that, and that was, you know, it was successful,
but it was limited of how many meals we could really do,
but then the pandemic hit
and obviously all the restaurants closed.
And so the supply to our commissary kitchens
to prepare these meals also stopped.
And I just found myself in this position
where I had this organization Rethink
where I had an empty kitchen, a massive professional,
empty kitchen where I knew a lot of cooks without chops
and where I knew all the farmers and producers
sitting on food that they're not selling anymore now.
And so we realized that we had to change what Rethink was.
And we sort of started this program
called Rethink certified.
And we allowed other restaurants,
any restaurant to use their kitchen
and their staff and their farmers to produce these meals.
And we as Rethink organization are buying these meals
from the restaurant.
So actually restaurants were able to keep people employed,
farmers who are able to keep supplying foods
and people were getting fed.
So that was a really pivotal moment,
changed the Rethink organization,
but also changed my belief of cooking for the 1%.
Because cooking for the 1% allowed me to have this voice
to be able to raise the funds we needed
to be able to get other people on board.
And so I promised myself
that if I would reopen 11 Madison Park,
it would have to have a higher purpose.
So today with every guest that comes to our restaurant,
we feed five people forward.
We actually started a food truck,
the 11 Madison truck in partnership with the Rethink
where we have 100 guests tonight, we give 500 meals per day
away for free in communities of need.
We cook the food in our own restaurant,
our staff that also cooks the fancy emails,
and then our dining room crew that serves our guests
in the restaurant also go out into these neighborhoods
and delivering these meals.
So it's sort of like a circular economy.
Right, right, right.
The problem of food insecurity and the problem of food waste
dovetail, because the solution to one
to the former can be found in the ladder in so many ways.
And we are in this extraordinary predicament where,
more than 50 million people
lack, reliable access to nutritious meals.
70 tons of good food goes under utilized every year.
If you talk to Paul Hawkin who wrote Draw Down,
he will tell you that food waste
is one of the biggest contributors to climate change
solving this problem in your local community is one thing,
scaling it in order to address the larger national
and sort of international issues
that relate to this is another thing.
But I think what's interesting
about trying to solve this problem,
grappling with the solution
orients itself around communication and distribution.
It's not food insecurity, isn't by dent of lack of food.
It's related to ineffectual distribution of the food
that gets wasted in so many restaurants
and homes every single day.
But to go to a busy chef or a busy restaurant
and layer on top of their impossible schedule,
the idea that they have to prepare meals or set aside,
it's like you're creating a situation
that's probably not gonna work.
So what I understand about Rethink is training chefs
and restaurants and creating systems through technology
and effective communication tools
that allow it to be seamless.
So it doesn't create a burden on these restaurants.
It just becomes part of how they operate.
Is that a fair?
No, I mean, what you're saying is absolutely accurate.
It's about communication and there is enough food
for everyone and that's what's so heartbreaking.
It is actually a problem we can solve.
There is actually enough food
and the restaurant business
is not the most lucrative business to be in.
And actually the goal of Rethink is actually
that it's a benefit to the restaurant to get on board,
to be a Rethink certified restaurant.
Yeah, so talk about that a little bit.
It's sort of like lead certification for restaurants.
And I think it plays into this idea
that especially amongst younger people,
purpose-driven companies, organizations
are really crucial in consumers
making conscious choices about the companies
and the businesses that they choose to patronize.
Yeah, for me, really the light bulb went off
right as the pandemic started.
And I decided that we would start cooking these meals.
I went to different soup kitchens around the city
to learn as much as I could
how they were operating and you know, how meals are packaged
and what were the meals consists of
and what gets good feedback and whatnot.
And I realized that all these soup kitchens
were run by volunteers.
And a lot of them weren't as well organized.
They also didn't have the connection that we have
to producers and farmers.
And so when we started producing these meals,
I was shocked how efficient we were.
We were able to produce 5,000 meals a day, pretty quickly.
That's a lot of meals.
We were efficient in time.
We were efficient at price too.
We were set...
We were told that a meal is probably $5 per meal.
And within a week, our meals were like around $2.
So then I realized that every restaurant
produces waste as well, like you said,
and I realized that the chefs and the restaurant
have a responsibility
and are in the center of this conversation
because we're talking to farms every day,
we're producing waste every day, we have talented cooks,
talented team members.
So the efficiencies in the restaurant are far greater than
in commissary kitchens.
And then the restaurants also struggle often to pay,
their rent and their staff and so forth.
And so if the organization is already paying soup kitchens,
they might as well pay restaurants.
So there's actually a great benefit.
Yeah, it gives them a base level of predictability
in their income that can create almost
like a universal basic income for restaurants.
As long as they're providing the service,
they know they can pay a certain percentage of their bills
and keep the lights on.
Absolutely.
How many people show up every day.
Yeah, that was exactly the idea.
It helps for pay for the rent.
It says it's a consistent income.
No one knows better than chefs,
how to cook delicious inexpensive meals.
You were sharing last night a little bit about
the impact of visiting these various neighborhoods
around New York City and really being boots on the ground
and developing a greater appreciation
and understanding for how most people
struggle every single day to get access to nutritious food.
So talk a little bit about that experience.
Yeah, I mean, it's shocking and it's unacceptable
that in a city like New York City,
that kind of poverty
and not accessibility to food is a reality.
I mean, yesterday I went to visit the Queensbridge
housing project because I'm really interested in,
you know, we, me as 11 Madison Park,
we can't change the entire world,
but we got to start somewhere.
So I'm really trying to figure out
where would it be the most meaningful.
So I've been visiting different community centers,
different community leaders.
I mean, the one thing that is so incredible,
you know, and there are so many bad neighborhoods
in New York and all over the country,
but even as bad as they are, there are always these angels,
these incredible people who are doing good,
who are helping others.
And sometimes you wonder, wow,
where do they take this energy from?
But it's just so beautiful and that has been consistent
in wherever I have visited.
And yesterday in Queensbridge,
I mean, this is a six block radius,
you know, square that has 69 apartment buildings
that houses 12,000 people.
And there's one little grocery store
where the fresh food section is one little corner.
I mean, just unbelievable.
There is no access to fresh food
and it's 20 minutes from here.
We're in downtown Manhattan.
Yeah.
So the solution rests and I mean, you can deliver meals,
you can deliver food to these communities,
but that's a kin to a band-aid in the sense that
rather than teaching them how to fish,
you're providing a fish, right?
So the long-term solution rests in
empowering these remarkable people in the communities,
these catalyst, these lightning rods for change
and providing them with the access
and the tools that they require
to empower their own neighborhoods.
And so much of that, I think can begin with teaching people
how to grow their own food
and leveraging all of the rooftops across Manhattan
and other urban areas across the country, in the world
to basically connect more deeply with the nutritious foods
that they so desperately need.
Yeah, I know, you're absolutely right.
And that's what we're learning as well.
Having this food truck in these neighborhoods,
it is just like an antenna to gather information.
And it is although every meal really matters
and people really rely on it.
It is a band-aid and the problems obviously go much deeper.
So we're really trying to figure out next steps.
And one thing that we're in the process of
is there's all this, you know, in next to Queensbridge
housing project, there are all these buildings
with empty roofs.
And so we actually secured a four acre rooftop space
where we are in the process of building a rooftop farm,
and hopefully create a farmer's market
for the housing projects
where people can use their food stamps
and prices are reasonable.
And then also have an educational program.
What's so beautiful about our industry.
The restaurant industry is that this is a great place
for people to come to who, you know,
didn't finish their schooling
or need a second chance
or even coming from a broken home.
The restaurant industry really allows for people to excel
if they bring passion to the work on it's on a daily basis.
Apprenticeship type career paths that still exists.
You're right, it's a beautiful industry.
And many of us need it you know,
I didn't finish high school.
You quit school at 14.
We're gonna get into that,
like left home at 15 it's bananas.
And look at you.
So there are many of us who found sort of a home
and family in a way too, in our industry.
So I'm very hopeful that we can attract some talent
from some of these neighborhoods.
Also our industry is not the most diverse,
which is an issue and I'm also a much thinking about that.
And it's like, why is that?
Because it doesn't actually make sense at all.
I promise you we'll be right back,
but let's talk for a minute, just a minute about hiring.
I run a small business over here
and let me tell you something,
I'm sure you already know this but hiring is hard.
it's really hard, so hard that I've learned the hard way.
It's also time consuming, it's imperfect.
All great reasons you gotta check out indeed,
which is the job site that makes hiring incredibly simple,
just attract interview and hire.
In fact, with Indeed,
you can do all of your hiring in one place
even the interviewing part.
Indeed's hiring tools help you cut through the noise,
the hire faster and smarter.
Indeed's instant match helps you make a short list
of great candidates fast.
The moment you sponsor a job,
you get a list of quality candidates whose resumes
on Indeed match your job description.
You can then invite them to apply right then right there.
Plus indeed makes finding quality candidates even faster
with 135 assessments to help make sure you find applicants
with the right skills.
Indeed is the number one source of hires in the US
helps you hire great people fast.
Best of all, you only pay for applicants
who beat your must have qualifications.
So get started right now with a $75 sponsor job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com/richroll.
Get a $75 credit at indeed.com/richroll.
Indeed.com/richroll offer valid through September 30th
terms and conditions apply.
And finally, we're brought to you today by Whoop, Whoop,
you heard me right.
You count calories, you might, maybe you should.
Do you evaluate your macros?
Do you track your run pace with extreme precision?
Sure, you can do all that stuff
but what about all those hidden invisible things
going on inside your body?
Things you can't sense or intuit
things like heart rate variability or metabolic rate
that are crucial data points in understanding
fully understanding how your body
is dealing with stress and strain.
If you indeed wanna truly understand
what goes into maintaining a consistently
high level of output, you gotta do what I did
and pick yourself up a Whoop,
which is basically the stylish very stylish fitness tracker.
You might've seen on my left wrist
that communicates personalized insights through their app
that actually lets you know how much sleep you need
each day, how recovered your body is to take on the day
and how strenuous your day was from everything you did
in and outside of training in the last 24,
Whoop sleep recommendations have been key
to the way I structure my day.
And I appreciate that Whoop tracks, all things sleep
from your sleep cycles, the stages, the disturbances,
the efficiency, all of which is fascinating
and super informative.
So if you're looking to be smarter about how you sleep,
recover, and train, so you too can be at your best.
You've gotta check out Whoop.
And right now for you guys.
My listeners Whoop is offering 15% off
when you use the code Rich Roll at checkout,
go to whoop.com that's W-H-O-O-P.com
and use the code Rich Roll at checkout
to save 15% off your order.
Unlock your best self today.
Okay, back to the show.
Let's talk about the pivot to taking 11 Madison Park
Plant-based it's one thing to do Rethink
and deliver all these meals and be part of the
solution of addressing food insecurity.
How does that relate to this you know,
basically Maverick in the food world decision
to drastically alter your menu and go 100% plant based.
Yeah, I think the pandemic definitely gave us all time
to kind of take a step back and think about everything,
rethink everything and I sort of thought about
what was really important to me
and to what were the things that got me to this place
and what got 11 Madison Park to this place.
And one of our, one of my main inspirations is Miles Davis,
who has been an inspiration for over 15 years.
And it kind of happened by accident,
but it was in her early, earlier review.
Write a review, said more, more miles day,
figure out what that meant.
So we came up with the list of 11 words
that were most commonly used to describe him
among the words cool, endless reinvention,
forward moving, light, innovative and so forth.
Is that the plaque that's in the kitchen
that I saw last night?
Exactly.
I was wondering where those words derived from.
And they became kind of our mission statements
and two of those words, endless reinvention
and forward moving and just thinking about Miles
and he has been such a deep inspiration
and it's been part of the success of the restaurant.
So what does this mean today?
Endless reinvention and forward moving
obviously means you have to change.
It's like Dylan going electric.
Yeah, or miles going electric
when he did pitches.
Yeah, yeah.
But you know, if I'm considered an expert in food,
if I'm truly at the forefront of dining
and if 11 Madison Park is truly
like one of the best restaurants in the world,
you know that as a chef, I've been cooking for 35 years,
I've seen products disappear.
I've seen the quality of products change,
and some of the luxurious products even more so
and we are a luxury brand that's just what it is
when I think about caviar for example.
And I think about that we are still celebrating that
as a luxurious product.
That is an old idea because caviar isn't wild anymore.
Caviar is not rare, it's plentiful.
You can find it everywhere.
You can buy caviar at the airport
and it doesn't even taste that good anymore.
So--
It's all farm raised now, right?
It's all farm raised
and we're still holding onto this idea
that this is one of the most luxurious product
that idea is broken.
And so if I'm that expert and I'm continued
and I've been guilty for it as well,
because we've still celebrate a caviar
when we already knew this, but coming out of the pandemic
and I think part of the issue is that
this is not just some artistic endeavor
this is our lives.
This is how we make our money and we need guests.
And so 11 Madison Park is selling an experience.
It's actually quite unique to other restaurants.
And during the pandemic,
I think that became clear to me
that what we're actually selling is not the food
that's on the plate
it's actually more like a Broadway show ticket.
And so we have the unique opportunity
to change people's ideas and thoughts
and what they think luxury is.
And I think my ambition was to create a meal
that wasn't as magical, as luxurious,
as delicious as a meal was before,
but without using any animal products.
And if we could do this, then maybe in a few years,
a restaurant can charge more for a carrot main course
or which today you still have to deal with
the cost of the staff and the cost of the rent.
And if you can only charge $20 for a main course,
because it's only plant-based, it's difficult.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Yeah, I mean, a couple of reflections on that.
First of all, change requires change at the top
and change at the at the bottom.
In other words, you need grassroots, groundswell, populist
change boots on the ground,
but you also have to at the highest level
set the tone for the rest of the culture
and you being in this privileged position
where the decisions that you make
and the menu that you arrive upon
has influence and impact across the food world.
And then trickles down into culture.
Like the power of that is huge to shift mindsets,
change perceptions, and create new trends.
If he can do this and be so successful.
I know when you made the announcement
and there was the food world just exploded
with a million hot takes on whether this was a good idea
or not but here we are,
you're only like a month into the reopening
and you've got a waitlist of 15,000 people.
I mean, the people have spoken,
this is something people are very interested in
it's successful and what does that mean
in terms of how people are rethinking for themselves?
What great food can be and how we can tie great food
to meaning and purpose in our own lives
to forge the future of our imagination
for the generations to come.
And that's a beautiful thing.
And at the same time,
secondly, this idea of creating an experience,
I experienced it last night.
It's unbelievable, like everybody knows your name.
The minute you walk in, Jeff had an umbrella,
the umbrella was taken heat.
There's no claim check, you know?
And then when we left, they remembered to give it back.
(laughing)
And Jeff was telling me stories about the Dreamweavers
and the magicians and all these iterations
of the restaurant over the years.
I mean, you used to have a couple people kind of wandering
anonymously the floor, semi eavesdropping on people.
And when somebody would say,
"Oh, wouldn't it be great if we have this,"
or "it's a bummer that our tropical vacation got canceled"
that suddenly you would materialize this experience
for people like magic which is unbelievable
to create that kind of experience for your guests.
Yeah, it's a really special place.
And it has gone through a lot of different iterations
and it has constantly evolved and moved forward,
but it was always very much about the guests
creating these magical moments for the guests.
And now I think we used to, at some point,
the menu was all about New York
and about all the artisans of New York
and the products of New York
and of course many other chefs have championed being local,
but I think today local isn't enough anymore.
And so we need to know, we need to show a delicious way,
a luxurious way in a different way.
I compared a little bit to when you look at the car industry
and you see when Toyota Prius came out with the hybrid car,
I think it's more than 20 years ago.
That was such a groundbreaking and incredible move and idea.
And but it wasn't the most sexy car.
And that's why it didn't really get the big attraction
at that time and it was really when Tesla
started making luxurious electric cars
that now the entire car industry is transitioning.
So--
And that's from the top down,
if Filan had introduced the first Tesla
as an economy vehicle, I'm not sure it would have worked.
His first car was like a $250,000 Roadster,
and they only produced a few.
So the idea being, create an aspirational brand,
you come out with the luxury product first
over time with scale,
you can create products that consumers
can get more accessibly.
Yeah, I think that's exactly.
That was my thought a little bit
that could have a massive, massive, massive impact.
Yeah.
Because we are going there actually.
Right.
This is--
So talk about that, I mean,
we still haven't gotten down to the nitty gritty of like,
why 100% plant-based, could you have a little fish?
Why don't, you know, why is there a little bit of me,
like, why are you so ardently doing this,
in this rigorous way,
as somebody who's been plant-based for 15 years, I get it.
I'm just interested in like your,
how you think about that for yourself.
Well, for us it was just exciting.
One part, it was exciting to challenge ourselves
to that kind of level.
Like in the beginning, it seemed so daunting
to let go of all these ingredients that we worked with
for so many years and even ingredients
that made our restaurant famous.
I mean, we perfected cooking the lobster during the duck.
And very rich food.
Yeah, mostly rich food.
But what I've learned is that by letting go of these things
today, I feel so liberated in a way
that I never thought was possible.
As a chef, I'm more excited than I've ever been.
And I feel my palette of ingredients has only grown
because before, in a way, we were stuck with these things,
you had to have lobster, you had to have the duck,
you had to have a photograph.
And today we're rewriting an entire new language.
It's not clear what the main course is gonna be
or the appetizer it's like the range of ingredients.
Yeah, it's creatively inspired.
I think there is something to this idea of constraints,
driving innovation in the way that an art,
if an artist is restricted in their color palette,
or a movie director is suddenly facing budget cuts
like those can, oh, we don't have 65 days
to shoot this movie we only have 28
and we're not gonna be able to get this or that.
And you're forced within those constraints
to come up with solutions.
And so often those solutions end up pushing the art forward
in ways that wouldn't have been possible
without those constraints.
So there is something about those boundaries
I think that really force you to dig deeper
into your talent and come up with something new.
And that's how we move culture forward.
Yes, I mean, we're not anti-meat, but we are pro planet.
I think that's one thing and if we can prove a way
that you can be completely without,
like for example, we feel like we've been working in food
our whole lives and we're very creative with it.
And where we apply our creativity, we wanna prove a way
to do it without animal products.
If someone orders a cappuccino at the end of their meal,
we're not gonna lecture you
what kind of milk you should drink.
We'll have plenty of plant-based milks,
but we'll also have the cow milk
because our we're not the food police.
You're breaking my heart.
I know I'm sorry.
But the most unreal sunflower butter last night,
and those rolls were extraordinary.
I can't believe there wasn't dairy in those.
I have to imagine that you could innovate
in the plant-based milk space to come up with something
that would sue the palette and disabuse people of this idea
that it has to be dairy in their cappuccino.
We're definitely working on all those kinds of things.
But we wanna lift people up to come
because most of our guests are not plant based eaters.
It's not a vegan restaurant for vegans?
No.
All the fancy vegan people are gonna come.
I know the have been coming.
Yes.
But that's not really the intention here.
The intention is to change people's ideas
of what it could be,
and that people will look, you know,
they will eventually make their own decisions
that they don't want cows milk and their cappuccino.
Has anybody come to the restaurant who was not aware
that you'd made this switch to plant-based
and had some kind of problem.
(laughing)
As a difficult 1% or it could be?
No, actually we we've been so blessed
with so many excited guests.
I mean, it's been...
And in a way it's almost like, wow,
really like everyone is liking it
because sometimes when you push creativity,
I'm sure as you know, to a really great place,
it's not universal.
Sure.
Liked.
But somehow this experience, somehow this has hit a nerve
that was very timely
and people are really responding extremely positively
to this experience.
And even the people who come in with a lot of doubts,
we definitely had some people
who made the reservation before COVID and have paid
before COVID and we're honoring their reservation now,
but it's obviously a very different question.
And some of those come in with a lot of reservations,
but I feel like people are really,
really living with excitement.
It's so cool, man.
Here's my theory, let me know what you think about this.
I think that you are on this spiritual journey
towards self-actualization
and deeper kind of integration within yourself.
Like you realized that you possess
a certain level of talent, a certain level of power,
and the pandemic has forced you
to try to find deeper meaning in that.
And you've come out with this marvelous thing
that you're doing right now.
And based upon kind of what you shared last night
about how you feel like you feel lighter,
you feel more directed, you feel more creative.
Like there is something to that you know,
mystical energy of aligning your guests
with something more meaningful and purposeful
that creates a more authentic being like a more self
and an integrated individual,
and based upon what you were sharing last night,
this is, I see this transpiring in you.
And I think it's just,
I think you'll continue on this journey.
I'm interested to see where it goes,
but how do you think about that?
How do you think about it from like a broader,
more like mystical perspective?
I know you're Swiss, you're precise and you know.
(laughing)
So I don't know what your relationship.
I don't know where you're going this,
but I kind of know.
You know, nothing is like,
that's what makes it interesting being Swiss.
It must be confusing for you, right?
So I can...
I can calibrate your watch to this.
I know, know you can.
I definitely, you know, after reaching the mountain top
of becoming the best restaurant in the world,
at a pretty young age,
I definitely asked myself a lot of questions
and I've done a lot of soul searching
and I've tried all kinds of things to soul search.
I went to India for two months,
which was incredible and I felt
it was challenging also.
I don't know if you've been to India.
I haven't no, my wife has.
It's an incredible place and a challenging place.
And you feel completely out of your comfort zone,
but it's extremely spiritual as well.
And I've done a few psychedelic journeys as well,
and, you know, just searching for more meaning
and for a fuller version of myself.
And I think, and I hope it's just gonna keep growing,
but today the work is definitely the most meaningful
and it feels like so many parts of my life
have led to this right moment.
Yeah, you told me last night that
you're almost quick to say that you're not vegan yourself
despite you know what you're doing in the restaurant.
And I think I said something like, well,
if you can dispense with that, you know, disconnect,
like if you can align your personal lifestyle
with what you're doing professionally,
I think you'll see an even greater kind of growth
or kind of celebration of what you're doing,
but I think you'll also feel more integrated
and purposeful in what you're doing.
I think you're probably right,
but the way I've always kind of lived my life
is more out of intuition
rather than so much about what I'm thinking.
I should do more my gut feeling.
And I think this has all come from that place
that I just felt like this is the right thing to do.
And I think my life just needs to catch up on
all of it's happening.
I think it's inevitable that instinct
that intuition will evolve as well.
It's absolutely happening.
I mean, even, you know, it will be strange for me
at this point to eat a plate of meat.
I haven't done it and it's almost the body's telling me,
you know, what the body's telling you
what's actually good for you.
Yeah, well, what happens is, as you continue to evolve
and grow those things become less appealing
and they just fall away effortlessly
as opposed to like, okay, now I'm gonna try really hard
to do this thing it just becomes incompatible
with the way that you're living.
Yeah, no and you know, and it's...
I do believe into talking things into existence
when I have some big ideas I just started talking about
even before I even fully comprehend what that means.
I mean, to--
It makes him real.
It does make him real, but also,
you know, it's a really scary thing.
Change is scary for a lot of people and I'm not in a,
you know, I'm in a team sport,
like there's a whole army to make this happen every day.
And it's not just what's in my head,
but it's like, I need to get everyone else on board.
Like what happened when you told your investors
are Like, this is what I'm gonna do.
No, he always says go, no there's,
so our building, we have a lease in our building
and it's owned by two different landlords.
I think when they bought the building few years ago,
it's like a billion dollar building or something like that.
And they're 50/50 partners.
And one of the partners reached out to the other partner
when they heard about my decision.
And they said, well, do we have any say in this
as the landlord of the building
I mean--
Oh, my God.
It was hard.
Yeah.
Obviously they don't,
but people really, it is hard for people to deal with change
and our team as well.
I mean, it was hard for our team to deal with this.
Yeah, it's a big deal.
It's scary though.
It's scary.
Well you don't get to this point,
you know, sitting at top of the pinnacle of cuisine
in the manner that you do without being competitive,
like behind your, you know, very charming disposition.
Like there's gotta be a killer in there,
right?
Yeah.
Like, and you're somebody who was a very good athlete.
Like I'm interested, let's go back.
Cause the origin story is crazy with you
growing up in a household where you had
a challenging, difficult relationship with your dad,
your mom introducing you to food at a young age.
But walk me through
what it was like growing up in Switzerland as a kid.
Yeah, I grew up with to as the youngest child
to my parents who were very young at that time,
my dad was going to architecture school,
you know, super detail oriented,
but tough, difficult dad and nothing was ever good enough.
And it was hard and I think that to the point
where you said earlier when there's yelling in the kitchen,
you know, there was yelling at home sometimes.
And it was also because it was just,
everything was overwhelming.
I mean, my dad was like, you know,
21 years old and there I was born
and he was also going to architecture school
and, you know, I think it was, is difficult.
And it was, I started biking a lot.
First--
You were runners up.
First I ran and sport for me was sort of the outlet.
I mean, the more time I could be out of the house,
the happier I was, I didn't really love school that much,
but I started running
and I started running even as a young kid, like for miles
and miles and miles.
And I competed in the, in cross-country
and that gave me the opportunity to travel around,
which was really exciting
when you're like 10, 11, 12 years old.
And I was running, I won the nationals two years in a row
and at a very young age as a junior,
but then, and then even running
wasn't even got me far enough.
So then I started biking because then I could do in travel,
you know, all--
But the dad, your dad wasn't giving you the love
on the running?
No love on the running.
No love?
You know, when I could come in first
and his response will be,
well, the best guys were injured or something like that.
You know, the guys who would have won were injured.
It was never really,
the winds were in really ever celebrated.
It was hard man sorry man.
It's hard.
It's, it is interesting that, you know,
I didn't have that specific experience,
but I did grow up underneath a dad
who set very high expectations for me
that I couldn't ever seem to quite satisfy.
And I've had to do a lot of work around that
to make peace with it and I love my dad
and, you know, he did the best he could
and he's from a different generation, et cetera.
But I think there's something about growing up
with that kind of parenting
or experiencing that kind of trauma that implants in you,
this competitiveness like this drive to excel
because you so desperately wanna be recognized and seen.
And I feel myself to this day still, you know,
I rely on that as a strength that can also lead me astray,
but it is in some respect,
like a super power that rested within me
because that was born out of that type of experience.
Yeah, that will be my dad's response to this.
How good, you know.
(laughing)
So then you get on a bike and then it's freedom
I'm outta here.
I can be gone like all day.
Yeah, I started racing and I started, you know,
pretty much winning a lot of races early.
And so I had the opportunity to leave school at 14 years old
to really become a professional cyclist,
to be part of a junior program for a serious team.
And for me it was like a no brainer.
I could leave home and school.
It was like a greatest I wanted to do it.
And so, yeah, that was amazing.
What did dad think about that?
Oh, it was so tough.
He didn't think it was a good idea at all,
but somehow I got away with it
and I went for it and that I did leave school at 14.
So, that's the last formal schooling that you had?
Yeah, I went to school for eight years of my life.
Wow, and mom?
I mean, she was crying
when I was leaving home,
because my mom, I was very, very close to her
and she was sort of like magical in Chicago
and spiritual as well.
Like she's an artist and for her it was just heartbreaking
for me to leave at that age.
But looking back at it, it was the best decision.
It actually suited me to go down this path.
Are they still around now?
Yeah.
How's it going now?
Well, my mom passed away, unfortunately.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, but my dad is around and you know,
I have an okay relationship
I think I agree I do love him too.
And also he did the best he could,
but it's hard to win when you are not supported at that age.
It's hard to ever fully come clear with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's tough, so you, you leave home at 15?
No.
And that was it?
And go be a bicycle racer.
Yeah, it was amazing.
What you did for many years right?
It was amazing I got to see all of Europe
and it taught me so, so, so much.
And I would never be the chef today
if I didn't have that as a background, as an athlete,
you know, like there's so many setbacks
and it is so tough and so competitive and--
There's this romantic idea around being a cyclist,
a professional cyclist, but the reality is so brutal.
There is no brutal.
You making no money.
Yeah.
You're living in your Belgium
or something middle of the winter
and terrible weather freezing all the time.
Eating raw manner or whatever,
barely making it enough to scrape by
and always worried about getting cut from the team.
Getting cut from the team, you know,
injuries are all the time.
Crashes, injuries it's just, yeah.
Eventually I had a bad accident.
I was 22 years old
and that kind of put everything in perspective for me
in a way grateful to that accident because I was in,
in the hospital for weeks and I realized that
this isn't going anywhere.
I was not on the past to be Lance Armstrong.
And there were only like two or three guys
on that level who actually made a living from it.
And that was in something that was in the cards for me.
And we also know about those times in cycling.
So it was just that kind of environment
that was very challenging and difficult.
And it actually only worked for a few
and not even in the long run.
Yeah, I mean, you have these very interesting
inflection points throughout your life
that are all defined by these 180 pivots that you make
from leaving home at 15 and saying,
I'm not doing school anymore to having the self-awareness
as a young person how old were you then?
18 or 21 or something like that.
When you have that crash.
21.
21 right, to say, this is not gonna work
and I'm gonna completely let it go.
That requires a certain level of maturity to do that.
It would have been easy to just keep going
and let it play out to its inevitable conclusion.
But to say, I'm pulling out of this
and I'm go gonna a completely new direction.
I think I'm--
It's the same thing when you decide
to make 11 Madison Park plant-based
like these very like hard line in the sand switch ups.
It's so liberating when you do though.
And it comes when I moved to America when I was 25
and I just left there was kind of a same similar moment
where I just left everything behind.
And I came with two suitcases
and I barely spoke the language,
but it is such a liberating feeling
to know that everything you need is inside of you.
You don't need anything else.
And I mean, only COVID could have given me this experience
again, so late in life at 44 years old,
where I was literally sitting in my apartment a year ago,
not knowing if I'm gonna have a restaurant,
not knowing how to pay for the bills for the business
and coming to terms with the idea I might lose it all
and it's okay.
And when you get to that place and I hope I can,
I hope I don't need to get physically to that place,
you know, again, but I hope mentally
I can get myself into that space
for many, many years to come because in that space
you're very free and you're able
to make pretty bold moves without fear.
But you did your work,
like you've been doing pushups all along.
Like you've made these pivots in the past,
you've taken these risks.
It's worked out for better or worse each time.
So when it comes to making this big,
more recent decision that you've made,
you already have that life experience of knowing
this is the only way
because this is the way I've always done it.
And somehow it always works out.
Maybe not in the manner in which I imagine
around the timetable, but short of doing that,
you rob yourself off the magic that can transpire
by deciding to incur that kind of risk.
Yeah, I think it only always works out.
Not because there's this success that's by your audience,
but it's the success that's you do,
what's in your heart and that's why it works out.
Like when you do what's in your heart,
then it's the right decision.
It doesn't matter if it's critically successful or not.
But if you continue to follow your heart,
I believe that gives you freedom and that, you know.
Yeah, yeah, so in the wake of the bicycle accident at 21,
walk me through the introduction to food
and that becoming like your path.
Well, as you said, as a cyclist,
you don't make a lot of money and I didn't either.
And so actually at 15, when I decided to go pursue cycling
as a profession my dad said, "Okay, you can do this,
"but you have to move out.
"I'm not supporting this."
And I said, okay, I'm not even fully understanding
what that meant but I had to get a job.
So when I was in training or traveling for races,
I had to find a job.
And the only place I could get a job was in a kitchen
at 15 years old.
And that was really lucky that I found a place
with a chef that became my mentor.
And it wasn't just a job, but he took it on him to teach me.
comes like a father figure.
He was like a father figure.
And by the time the accident happened,
I've actually already cooked for six years.
And my mom was an excellent cook
and even more so she really put a lot of value
on the ingredients.
Like we got all of our vegetables from the farm,
everything from the farm, like fresh milk every day,
she would bake her own breads.
We would pick our own salads in the fields.
And so, you know, as a kid that was annoying,
but because so much work to prepare the meal,
but it gave me this understanding
of what a great ingredient was.
So in a way I was set up for it without even knowing,
I never thought I would pursue cooking as a career,
but when I was in the hospital
and I thought about the cycling,
I actually didn't like cycling as much anymore.
It just became something so different.
They became so, so, so competitive.
And it wasn't enjoyable.
And when I thought about where I found pleasure
was when I thought of the moments in the kitchen,
and then I thought well, I should just do that.
And if I can't become the best cyclist in the world,
maybe I can become one of the best chefs.
Was that at a very concrete decision that you made?
Like do you have awareness
that you were making that kind of pivot
and refocusing all of your intentionality into this?
Okay, okay, I was all in on cycling
now I'm going all in on this.
Yeah, this happened in one day
Wow.
This was one moment when I made that decision.
And then one of my trainers was close to this restaurant
that had three stars
it was in the French part of Switzerland.
And we ate there once after a race and it was so magical.
Like we, we sat in that kitchen
and that was actually the first time
I saw cooking on this level.
That was actually that kind of plant that the seed
that cooking could be a sport or career,
but we were sitting in the middle of this three
Michelin star restaurant.
It was called Freddie Sheraday.
And they were like 25 chefs working all around us.
Like similar to what you saw last night at our restaurant.
But everyone had perfect starched uniforms
and big tokes the hats.
And they were serving us the most incredible meal.
And they were working in harmony
and it was like watching a balley
and sort of that planted a seed
and yeah, I was in the hospital and I called my coach
and I said, do you remember that dinner
we had two years ago can you call that guy?
I wanna work there.
And he said, what?
He's just like, well, I don't wanna race anymore.
-You're baring the lead.
And he did it and he did.
And then three months later I had a job.
Wow, Wow.
And is that the restaurant?
What was the restaurant that you were working in
when you had the accident on route to the farmer's market
at like three in the morning?
That was later, right?
That was later, that was a few years later.
I was working in this little restaurant.
That was actually my first place where I was the chef
and I was 25 years old and I would go to the market
every morning to Sarek it was an hour away
and this was in a mountain town.
And one morning there was so much snow
and I was so tired probably slept four hours.
And I got up at five in the morning to drive to Sarek
and yeah, and the car just went out of control
and I was sledding down this hill and I hit a tree
and I was super lucky that there was a tree.
Cause short of you angled the car
towards the little twig of a tree, because short of that,
you were looking at an Alpine cliff that it would have
certainly met your death.
Yeah, it would have killed me.
Wow.
And then I called the farmer of this place
and he came with the tractor and he pulled me out.
Like the thing, man, I need to reassess my priorities
instead you're like, I gotta get to the farmer's market
because the restaurant can't operate.
Once I get there and get the stuff.
Like the level of obsession at that moment in your life
layered on top of which you've got a very complicated
personal situation you had a kid at 18.
Like you had an older girlfriend who then left you,
which you know, the pain of that forces you
to just go all in on career.
I won't be hurt.
Nobody can abandon me.
This is the one thing that I can control
and just literally becoming obsessed.
Yeah, I know that's right.
Yeah, it's not always healthy, but it definitely pushes you.
It definitely, yeah, you have to push yourself
to extreme levels to reach the success.
And that's what you learn in sports.
It's--
100%.
Not who is the most talented
is like who can hurt the most actually.
Well, especially in cycling
Yeah.
Because nothing, there's no sort of self-inflicted
suffering can be experienced like it can be on a bike.
Yeah, I know, that's right.
And you learn that.
But this then gets channeled into this discussion around
passion like we live in a culture,
it's like chase your passion.
We should all live passionate lives.
And what I love about the way that you think about this
is the fact that it's filtered through the German
definition of passion, this idea of lightened shaft.
So explain that because I think it's really profound
and it's so much of a better way
to think about this type of lifestyle.
Yeah, no, in German, the word passion is light and shaft
and light and is actually suffering
and shaft is sort of like enduring,
you know, endure, suffering,
or being willing to suffer for something
because that's really passion.
Otherwise it's just like the hobby,
but if you're passionate about something,
you know, are you willing to suffer for it?
Yeah, exactly.
And the suffering will inevitably come.
It will be visited upon you
because doing anything well is fucking is hard.
And if you wanna be at the highest level,
prepare yourself, like there just aren't that many people
who are willing to kind of endure what it's going to take
to get to the peak, whether it's in cycling
or running or being a chef or any other goal or dream
that you're chasing, that's just the truth.
But it's the journey that is beautiful
and there is suffering,
but there's also so many beautiful parts
and the moments of suffering make the beautiful moment.
You can't have one without the other.
That's exactly right.
You know, you can't and even with that,
like when you were talking about reaching number one
and you think, oh, I've been vying for this for a decade
and then it gets there and it's you find it lacking
in a satisfaction that you were expecting.
And that's always the case.
Because the value is in the endeavor,
it's in the getting there, it's in the journey undertaken,
it's in the hardship and the struggle and the suffering,
the lightened shaft that is packed into
trying to aspiring to that place.
It's not the arrival. The arrival is a footnote.
The journey is over kind of when you write and--
And then you're there you're like now what?
Right?
Yeah.
Like that's a scary place to be.
Yeah, short of you figuring this out for yourself,
like short of COVID kind of compelling.
Now this introspection on your level,
it would have been interesting to see
what would have happened.
It was difficult, like I know COVID has been devastating
and obviously super painful for a lot of people
and a lot of loss and it's devastating.
But in my case it's really,
I've found a lot of positive in it.
And before now before I was this chef
that was named number one at some point,
and the reservations were booked and booked
and booked and booked.
And I became more of a brand than a person.
And so many of my partners wanted to monetize this brand.
People saw opportunities to open different concepts,
you know, casual concept alignment with brands
and all this kind of stuff.
And I started completely losing myself.
I wasn't even in charge of my own schedule in a way anymore.
It was just like, I was this face of this brand
that a lot of people were interested in but I wasn't.
And so it was really challenging.
And when everything fell apart during COVID,
I was really able to cut ties with a lot of organizations,
a lot of partners, a lot of projects
in a way that I don't know if it would have been possible.
Yeah, your entrepreneurial journey is fascinating
as this hybrid of how do you blend art and commerce
in a way that is successful.
It's a difficult recipe to get, correct.
You've had all of these successes along the way
and all these different kind of incarnations
of partnerships from Danny Meyer originally bringing you in
to 11 Madison Park in the first place.
And then you and Will Gadara,
is that how you say his last name.
Kind of purchasing or Danny selling you the restaurant,
and then you having this partner
and this fruitful partnership with this guy
in which you create all of these amazing opportunities,
but ultimately your life scales out of control.
You become a brand, you become a licensing vehicle.
And then to cut ties with all of that
and narrow your focus to just literally this one,
like let go of the hotels and all the kind of stuff.
Just say, I wanna get back to the one thing
that I love that gives me creative sustenance
is a bold move in and of itself.
And now here you are like, you have investors,
but essentially you're the proprietor
and sole owner of this restaurant.
You've got one in London as well,
but to have the kind of sensibility to say bigger,
isn't necessarily better.
It's moving me away from what I'm actually seeking.
Yeah, you know what's interesting is that all associations
partnerships in my case, I think or most of all,
we're actually needed and beneficial.
And it got me to this point.
I mean, it's starts with even just in a restaurant.
When you think about the need for guests,
in the beginning, you need to kind of cook the food
that guests will want and will pay for.
And then only slowly you can kind of come into your own
and you can add some creativity to it.
And I tell you what you like.
Yeah, I mean, I love it.
I don't know what they want.
That's my job.
But we're still doing it today.
I mean, today we're cooking completely plant-based
people don't even want, you know,
know that they would like that.
But the meal starts with this essence of tomato,
just simple tea of tomato that is sort of like disarming
and no matter who you are.
You're shocking people
into you're giving them the sense like
this is gonna be unlike what you expect it to be
like when it's placed down in front of you.
There's no explanation of what it is.
I thought, oh, this is a tea
or we're gonna cleanse our palette and get ready.
And then you take one sip and you're like, whoa,
I've never had anything like that before.
Certainly you taste the tomato,
but clearly it's a distillation of,
I don't know how many thousands of tomatoes are compressed
to get like that density of flavor into this clear broth.
Yes.
And inevitably you think, okay,
this is gonna be a ride, like no other.
It's intentionally vague, simple, easy to digest
and very, very delicious, universal, delicious.
And so it's, then we can take people on a journey
then they're like, it's kind of like a hug.
It's like, it's gonna be a great meal.
I trust you.
Exactly and that's with the cooking
and that's with partnerships.
Like I needed certain partners to understand
how business works in America.
I had no idea, I came from Switzerland.
I left school at 14.
Do you know, and now I'm running an empire
here in New York city.
I mean, it really is crazy.
You know, I needed these steps if you will.
But if you get to the place and proudly I can say,
I don't have an investor anymore.
And it took 44 years old.
Wow, and you're the sole owner.
Yeah, I could have this decision to go plant-based
I don't think, I don't know if there's an investor out there
who would have said, oh, this is a great idea.
We just had, COVID now go plant-based.
You know, I don't know if that investor is out there.
That's liberating
It's liberating.
You know, land, you got landlords and all that,
but you know.
No, no.
It's pretty cool.
What is in your mind, the distinction between good and great
with food, like there are plenty of good chefs.
What goes into being a great chef
for people that aren't steeped in this type of this world,
this subculture, like how do you think about that?
That's a big question.
I think, you know, foremost it's,
I think cooking is, is a craft.
And I think there are amazing, amazing restaurants
where you just go and have an amazing meal
with amazing source ingredients prepared
in a beautiful way.
And then in the rare cases,
it kind of can transcend that
and it can actually add something.
I talked about culture earlier, how fine dining
is a big part of culture.
And the language of sorts, like, you know,
we know that there are a lot of different languages
that the languages of politics and the languages of art
and different kinds of arts.
And I think there's a language of food.
And I think chefs through history of time,
have, you know, when you think of Alice Waters,
I don't know it's in the 70's probably when she,
you know, really made a big stand on local food that was
ground breaking and it was, it really changed culture.
It changed America.
And there's been other chefs in history of time before.
So I think way rarely there's someone that comes along
and that really can make that kind of right kind of impact.
Is it an intangible like I know it when I taste it
or see it or feel it, or are there criteria
like when you sit down at a restaurant and you're surprised,
and you're like, this is great.
And this is great because XYZ,
like can it be distilled down into variables
that you feel are important ingredients
in making a proclamation that a certain chef
or a certain restaurant, you know,
stands or sits above its competitors?
To me, it's like, when it's bigger than the restaurant,
to me, it's, there is the craft
and when you're in a restaurant of great craftsmans
and great chefs, then you're in the restaurant
and you taste it and you see the attention to detail
and the way the flavors are balanced
and it's harmonious and all that.
And then there are a few restaurants
where it's bigger than the restaurant
where it's about something bigger and you,
and that's just a feeling.
And that's just when it's like,
almost like it gets some construct
where everything is from the place to the people
to dedication of the people, to the plate where,
to where it's this one idea of, I guess, I'm construct.
And then it can really make real big impact
that will trickle down to all kinds of industries.
Yeah, there's the, you know, hero dreams
of sushi type mastering.
And then there's the kind of orchestration
of scaling up that mastery to cultivate
an extraordinary experience.
It's interesting.
It's something that I think, you know,
to kind of pivot back to the mystical a little bit,
there's a saying,
I was talking to Jeff about this last night,
long time in recovery,
and there's an adage in alcoholics anonymous
that you can't transmit something you haven't got,
like you have to carry the vibration within you
to be the lighthouse that will attract the energy
into your life that you aspire to have.
You can't fake that.
Like you're either living it and you're being it,
or you're a pretender.
And increasingly I think people are antenna for what is real
and what is authentic is never been more finely honed.
Like we can all see coming a million miles away,
and we can all identify when something is real
or something is different or carrying that vibration
that we wanna be around.
You know, and I think the more that you instill that
in yourself and in the culture that you create
in your kitchen, you know,
the more that, that will resonate out into the world
and attract those kinds of people into this mission
that you're on of transforming food and security.
I think that's really well said.
And I think so true.
I think authenticity, you feel if it's authentic or not.
And I think the one thing I do believe though,
is that if you do not perfect the craft,
you will never get.
It's lost right to the neck.
And you can't, there's a lot of people who break rules,
but they they never took the time to master the craft itself
and really understand the rules.
Like you can't paint outside the lines
until you really know how to paint
you know, with mastery within the lines.
Yeah, that's why art is such a great inspiration to me.
And I, you know, most of my friends are painters
or sculptors or dancers.
And it is so interesting when you follow,
for example, Mondrian, most people know, you know,
Mondrian one of the first abstract painters.
But when you look at his early paintings,
they weren't abstract at all.
There are landscapes and beautiful ones,
but then at some point he became Mondrian.
It's always amazing to see early works
of some of those more modern artists
who are doing radically different things
and to realize like, oh, they actually,
they can do it the other way.
Yeah, that's right.
That's makes it brilliant.
Yeah.
Right.
Well, art has been so crucial and influential
in how you think about food
and just the restaurant experience in general.
So talk a little bit about that influence
and also how it's kind of informed some of these pivots,
you know, specifically going from this very,
I wouldn't say sensory overload experience,
but kind of a robust sensory experience
to trimming things down into a more minimalistic approach.
I've heard you talk about minimalism
before I would characterize it more as essentialism,
like getting rid of anything that's not informing,
you know, the experience or the art
that you're trying to share.
Yeah, I think that's really good observation.
I actually call it elemental,
like where everything is stared that's needed,
but nothing.
Nothing extraneous.
Yes.
For me, when I was 12 years old,
I had my first real experience with art
and my parents took me to the Lorawan Sheree in Paris.
And, you know, that's where it's the museum
where they hold the large Monet Water Lily paintings.
And it's sort of these two oval rooms
of just Monet Waterlilies.
And as a 12 year old kid, you just feel like
you're totally wrapped into these paintings.
And for the first time I had this experience,
when I didn't know how I was feeling,
did I, was I happy?
Was I sad?
It was really bizarre.
It was very emotional.
And since then I knew that art was speaking to me
and was really important to me.
And I think forever since then, I've put wherever I go,
I visit artists studios.
I go to museums, I go to galleries and I read about art.
And I think I had another really meaningful experience.
And that was probably at the age of like 24
when I saw for the first time I saw Lucho Fontana,
these paintings where he it's just a canvas, a white canvas,
and he took a knife and he just cuts through the canvas.
Yeah.
And a friend of mine took me to see that show
and said, "Hey, this is a really important artist.
"And you should, you know, really dig in on him."
And I didn't really understand what--
What the fuck the is this.
Exactly.
He literally took a knife
and slashed the middle of a white canvas.
But my friend was very knowledgeable so I trusted him.
And in the next few weeks,
I tried to understand why this painting was so important.
And it's exactly to the point that you said,
because he was Fontana was while a great sculptor.
He worked in ceremony Airmax,
but he could also paint anything.
I mean, he was just a really accomplished artist.
And at some point he decided that
he would just cut the canvas and that's his master piece.
And that painting in fact changed art forever.
Because with that one slid in the canvas,
he questioned everything that sort of was there before,
like does the canvas need to have a painting?
Is art on the canvas?
Could the canvas be the art?
Could the artwork be behind the canvas?
I mean, he questions, everything is painting sculpture
Or is the art the conversation around the work itself.
Yeah, as well
Yeah.
So taking that like,
what do you make of that for yourself?
Like why was that so impactful to you
and how does that get channeled
into how you think about food
and the experiences that you're providing?
The more I thought about that work was
he changed art forever with the way minimal gesture.
And for me, that was just so powerful and so mind blowing.
And so this is how I wanted to cook.
I wanted to cook very minimal, but say a lot.
And I realized that was a lot harder than,
than it seemed because the gesture has to be so strong
and there is nowhere to hide.
And as a young chef, often I had two ingredients
on the plate and I was like, that's not a complete dish.
No one would think that's great.
So then I added things.
I said, oh, I need to know the puree and other ingredients
and other texture.
And it became more complicated.
But at that point, you know, guests were reacting
to this more than they would have
with two ingredients on the plate.
And it took a long time for me to get to the place
where I could have two ingredients on the plate.
And it probably only happened like four years ago.
In the way that was it, Alice Waters,
who would just say, here's two dates on a plate that's it.
It takes a lot to get there.
It takes a certain level of audacity.
Confidence.
Yeah.
But you're not lacking in confidence.
Well, thank you.
I don't know if that's a compliment, you know,
no, I mean, it's, I guess,
you know, courage is probably a better word, like to say.
I have a strong enough sense of self in what I'm doing,
that I can put this out there
and maybe not be certain, but have some level of confidence
that it will be received because it's backed up
by this lifetime of experience.
And this trust that you've encountered gendered over time.
Is that accurate?
How does that one feel?
(both laughing)
I backed myself in a corner.
You know, what am saying.
It takes a long time to be very simple.
Yeah
Yeah.
Yeah, and that's reflected in the, in the Rita Ackerman
painting in the restaurant.
The chalkboard painting that's very stripped down.
That's on one far side of the wall hanging,
hanging high up that kind of to me symbolizes,
like we can always erase this and start fresh or new,
like nothing is permanent.
It's a reminder, like this is a process.
Yeah, it's like Picasso said,
you know, "A painting is it's never finished
"it's only abandoned."
Yeah, and I think that's true.
That's true of everything that's true
Whether you're writing a book or preparing meals,
I mean, the difference with cuisine,
yes, there's this constant every day you're doing it.
It's evolving, it's an organic living breathing thing.
But each meal in and of itself is almost like a Zen Mandola
because it will be consumed and destroyed, yeah.
What's hard in our.
It's impermanent.
Yeah it is impermanent and, you know,
there's an artist called Andy Goltz
where the, which we're very inspired by
and he works in nature a lot
And and he makes like sculptures out of icicles and,
he builds them and then the sun come.
And they're gone.
And they're gone or he ties these leaves together
and he lets them run down the river and it's so beautiful,
but it's impermanent.
It's hard to...
It's beautiful because I think a lot in life,
the impermanent things make it magical.
But as a creator, it's also difficult
because you know, you had dinner there last night
and there was someone else gonna have dinner tonight.
And we have to recreate that moment over and over
and over again.
Do you think about the kind of mystical aspect
like putting things inside of people's bodies.
Like I've created this thing
it carries a certain vibration and a certain vitality.
Other people are consuming that.
And then they're going out into the world,
this sort of diaspora of human beings
who are carrying that vibration.
I mean, Jeff was talking about last night
the first time he ate at the restaurant
and you know, as a long-time food critic can writer
he is used to go these restaurants
and they kind of just give him a million dishes
and he rolls out of there and he feels like shit.
You know, even though the food is boring,
but in the case of 11 Madison Park with the new menu
feeling like vital and elevated
he said like a couple of days, you know,
even though he's not like he wouldn't consider himself,
plant-based, I think he's, you know,
playing around with that in his idea.
But there is something to that of
you are providing a certain wavelength of energy
and putting it into other people's bodies.
And that has like that activates people
and puts them on their own kind of journey of exploration,
their own like trajectory of like learning and exploring
and growing and evolving.
Yeah, I mean, it's a humbling to know that,
you know, what we're creating people are eating ingestion.
And I think there's, it's really interesting,
even beyond our knowledge of what's actually happening
during this meal.
Like we...
It's a fully plant-based meal,
but we're working a lot more with different cultures.
And that actually, you know,
when we talk about removing a lot of ingredients of animals,
the one ingredient that came up a lot
was the ingredient of time.
Like the time it takes to ferment something,
or you know, we're working on all kinds
of different fermentations of sauces and show use.
And you get an like a soy sauce is like, gives you an idea,
but there are so many.
It's endless.
It's endless what you can do, not from soy,
but from so many other things.
And when we removed meat
we felt like we wanted to still have a meal
that is balanced of like where there are some dishes
are more light, some dishes are more,
I'm gonna use the word meaty, but richer.
And so Umami is definitely very central in this cooking.
We also worked with these Buddhist monks
who are cooking a cuisine called Shogun.
And we learned about the ingredient of time
we learned about using different cultures
in different dishes, like cultures from, yeah,
different, you know, we ha we were working with a lab
called kingdom culture,
who they have a library of cultures from around the world
from like Sauerkraut or kimchi or.
Cultures you didn't, you mean not populations of people,
you mean literal like biological cultures.
Lamentation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I think it affects people.
I think during a meal,
having eating these biological cultures
is affecting people almost to a place where
people feel euphoric in a beautiful way.
And I think that's what Jeff is sort of talking about.
And we don't even fully understand.
I think Michael Pollan said that,
you know, we know the body so well,
many parts of the body we know so well,
but actually what's happening in our gut.
Our knowledge is so limited.
It's like, so I think there there's a lot of work
that's still that's gonna happen.
Yeah, it is this amazing amalgam
of all these different influences and cultures.
You mentioned the Japanese tradition,
Buddhist temple food, ideas from India, China,
Nouvelle cuisine from France in the 70s,
Boulay, Patterson, Pissarro, like all of these influences
being kind of hybridized
and uniquely kind of through your, you know,
unique perspective creating something new all of that.
The host last night was sharing about the grinding
of the Sesame seeds every day
and how that's almost become, it's like a team activity.
But it's almost like a group meditation
that begins every day with this laborious process.
That's amazing.
Yeah, and like, how about like the people
that have to chop the cucumber in the daikon?
One dish, where you spend all day just doing that
for that one dish.
Yeah, it's extremely labor intensive.
But there's something about that's beautiful.
It's like so much heart is required to do that
when you take it in, there is some,
I think there is something intangible about like that,
that is impactful.
One of the Buddhist monks who was with us
for this last year in New York, his name is Toshio.
And he said, he thinks that we should have the guests
also (indistinct) before their meal.
We should yes, yes.
Here, this is gonna cost you an arm and a leg
now go in the back room.
Cause you can't appreciate it.
How could you possibly truly appreciate
what has gone into this
unless you're actually doing some part of it.
But you know, I mean, it's a wild idea,
but when you do the Sesame grounding
is central to the cooking, descend, Buddhist cooking.
And you literally sit on a floor on your knee for an hour
and you're with this wooden pedal
and you're grinding the Sesame seeds counterclockwise
because on this side of the earth,
everything in nature goes counter clockwise.
And first of all, it's really painful to sit for an hour
on your knees.
Like almost unbearable.
It's unbearable the first few times you do it.
And then it becomes sort of bearable.
And then to grind for an hour by hand is hard.
And it's this meditation, that's ought it's like passion.
You know, you'll really have to work for it.
But then when you're done, you're in a different mindset.
And I think that's his point
of having the guests participate.
That's the power it cleanses at.
That's the required preparation to put you in the state
of mind to receive.
That's right, appropriately.
Wow, we gotta wrap this up
cause I know you've gotta go in a minute here,
but I think a good place to kind of close it
is to talk a little bit about the New York
of your imagination like if you can continue to scale,
rethink and you start getting more invested
in the communities that require food assistance,
like how can this transform this city
and set an example for the rest of the country in the world,
because basically what happens in New York,
like then percolates out like New York
is the place from which culture emanates in so many ways.
And you have this opportunity
that you're taking advantage of to lead by example.
So how does this, you know,
how would you like the world to perceive this and how can
people or restaurant tours
or chefs or cooks who are tuning in for this
start being part of this solution as well?
Well, I think the one thing to remember is that,
sometimes you get,
when you hear the numbers of food insecure people
in New York or America,
the number is so big that you ask them to feel like, wow,
I'm not able to make a difference here.
What differences that make
like the number of food insecure, New Yorkers
during the pandemic was 2 million,
2 million people a day.
And so we cooked 5,000 meals a day, which is a lot of meals.
Just imagine the amount of boxes, trucks, everything,
5,000 compared to a million it's nothing.
So on some days I was like, wow,
we're never gonna make a dent into this.
But then when you go into these neighborhoods
and you're actually giving the meals away,
you're realizing that every single drop matters
and every meal matters.
And so--
I think it's not a drop to them.
It's not a drop to them.
And I think that's when it, if everyone out there
does what they can, the smallest thing matters.
And in their community, there are amazing organizations
all over and they're always looking for help.
Yeah, I mean, there are plenty of other organizations
out there that are doing this kind of work.
I just had Maggie Baird on the podcast.
Who's Billy Eilishs' mom.
She's got an organization called support and feed.
She's doing essentially the same thing.
Jaden Smith in LA has his, I Love You Truck.
He goes down to Skid Row and he delivers plant-based meals.
Amazing.
But I feel like the power of Rethink
is to create these organizational tools,
to establish efficiencies in communication and distribution
so that all of the various people who are doing good work
can align in a certain way that can,
you know, establish the kind of scale required
to address the problem in a macro meaningful way.
I think using the infrastructure that already exists
is probably the most powerful way we can actually
make a difference and in particular,
if we can even make the infrastructure stronger,
because there are already funds a lot of funds
going towards food insecurity,
but a lot of the systems are so antiquated,
Some of these food banks and where the money goes to,
it's just so antiquated.
So I think that has to be rethought to where the money flows
and using the existing infrastructure
that can strengthen it.
Yeah, good man.
Well, I appreciate your time.
Thank you.
It was pleasure talking to you.
I can keep you here for two more hours.
I don't know things,
I wanted to talk to you about your daily routine
and what your exercise looks like. I got lots of...
Maybe at some point you can indulge me
via a part two to this,
but I really appreciate you taking the time to do this.
No, I really have talk to you.
I really appreciate.
What you're doing is meaningful, it's important.
I was personally very impacted by my experience last night.
And if there's anything I can do to help you,
I am at your service, my friend.
Thank you, I really appreciate it likewise.
Once again, I wanna thank Joe at New Stan studios
here at Rockefeller Center for providing the space
for us to have this conversation.
You can follow them at Rockefeller Center on Instagram
or at Rock Center NYC on Twitter.
And until next time my friend,
you gotta get to the restaurant probably right?
I do service is starting.
Yeah, you're pretty mellow.
Considering like you have to put on this crazy show
every night, it's wild.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Peace, plants.
Peace, yes.
(soft music)
Thank you for listening, everybody for links and resources
related to everything discussed today,
visit the show notes on the episodePage@richroll.com.
If you'd like to support the podcast,
the easiest and most impactful thing you can do
is to subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts on Spotify
and on YouTube sharing the show
or your favorite episode with friends or on social media
is of course always appreciated.
And finally, for podcast updates, special offers on books,
The Meal Planner and other subjects,
subscribe to our newsletter,
which you can find on the footer
of any page on richroll.com.
Today's show was produced
and engineered by Jason Camiolo.
The video edition of the podcast was created Blake Curtis,
portraits by Allie Rogers and David Greenberg,
graphic elements, courtesy of Jessica Miranda,
copywriting by Georgia Whaley.
And our theme music was created by Tyler Piatt,
Trapper Piatt and Harry Mathis.
You can find me@richroll.com or on Instagram
and Twitter @rich roll.
I appreciate the love.
I love the support.
I don't take your attention for granted.
Thank you for listening.
See you back here Soon.
Peace, plants (indistinct)
(soft music)